all right so my baby brother is getting
married on this trip we're out here in
boston to celebrate terry and diana's
wedding well actually they're getting
married in rhode island but we stopped
in boston this is part of the trip
[Music]
all right what are we doing today we're
in salem today we just walked out of the
witch city mall we're doing another vlog
vlog exception
vlogging to follow his channel he said
this will probably go nowhere
[Laughter]
to the salem witch museum to go find out
about the salem witches oh yeah you guys
are matching shoes nice you guys plan it
yeah
if you guys want to learn more there's a
qr code
i should have done this before but i'm
now downloading the freedom trail
self-guided
so it actually costs like 6.99 so i'm
just gonna google it
the dome was covered in copper by paul
revere
[Music]
hi papadito
hi goodazoon hi my happy baby what'd you
think of the salem witch museum kind of
boring
it was but i mean interesting but like
boring the presentation in the beginning
was fun the second half was kind of like
i don't want to walk around
we weren't able to capture any footage
in there because they said no recording
no photography we learned a lot about
witches though you did what did you
learn the thing i learned that i was
like that's fascinating the most was the
fact that they didn't have a skin color
like a particular skin color for the
wizard of oz wizard of oz yeah that was
cool and it was only afterwards because
they had technic color and they were
like let's colorize this whole thing and
make it crazy
what is the craziest color we could pick
green and so that that revolutionized
the whole witch thing like forever oh
look hey
so this kid is like full on teething
he's been attacking everything
[Laughter]
hey silly boy
your little rascal
oh
still smiling okay it's okay
everything's okay i think he got dizzy
so he was staring at once you see this
guy
oh yeah he got scratched by him me too
right here i have a stretch right here i
filed your nails this morning so
hopefully
you don't scratch anymore all right so
now we are in front of the uh
the uh what is this gazebo i was about
to say the pagoda a pergola this is
where my brother had uh proposed
reenactment
all right so it was raining that day
raining we got here we went to a coffee
shop uh to use the bathroom or whatever
yeah it was raining so i asked if they
had any umbrellas and they're like yeah
we got a bunch of the lost and found and
then i picked one out romantic and we
started walking in in the rain with the
umbrella and we realized that there were
holes in the umbrella oh not romantic
there was water coming through but the
water was kind i mean the rain wasn't
like raining raining it was just kind of
drizzling-ish romantic it wasn't too bad
got here and there was people already
standing in here you know just what'd
you do you thought to yourself ah dang
it yeah get out yeah
there's people there you're already
planning on doing it here yeah like from
the get-go yes because i don't know it's
a gazebo
it's nice in the middle of this
beautiful uh
oh it's beautiful we got here for like a
minute and magically everyone just left
so i was like oh nice and that was i
suggested oh let's go up there let's
let's you know stand up here
then we got up here and it was kind of
all a blur from there
and i just waited for the right moment
how did it feel to get down on one knee
weird yeah it's like it's like you've
never kneeled down before in your life
like i've never done oh my god i don't
know how to kneel anymore yeah and it's
just like what is she gonna think and
you know yeah nervous all around and i
mean i knew she was gonna say yes but
you know just the act of doing it yeah
it's nerve-wracking are you gonna
re-enact it i wanna see yeah re-enact
re-enact reign
we all in the middle middle like right
there
i'm gonna get the marine act hold on
yeah are you guys in the middle like
they're right there right here oh and
then you were kneel down which leg
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
did you have any idea that uh carrie was
gonna propose to you that day the only
clue that i had was that he was being
extra nice and he was like opening all
of the doors he doesn't normally do
those things oh no obviously like
whenever like we're
like going to the store or going home or
whatever but
like particularly car doors like every
single one like no matter where we went
like that part he doesn't normally do so
i'm like gotcha
he started talking really weird like
really weird like he was stumbling his
words and he was so nervous
and i'm like
are you about to
you know do what i think you're about to
do and then it was so funny because it
actually sounded like it was actually
beating around the bush like he was so
nervous he couldn't even like say
anything
about how we've been um together for
like a long time and i don't remember it
it was really cute though like a
two-liner i think i don't know i mean i
made it short right no you made it long
i don't know i don't remember it i'm
glad no one was there to witness or
there was no recording because that just
keeps it you know
yeah it was awesome probably it's a
sacred moment for you guys everybody
loves a good romance story but you
actually asked will you marry me yeah
yeah yeah
he never asked me when he proposed he
just he finished the line that he wrote
out that was being read
or something about like you complete me
and that was it
and then people were like so yes yes
like did you say yes and i'm like i
think i ever said i didn't ask i didn't
get asked the question was implied yeah
i mean i'm on one knee there's a ring do
i really need to say anything else i
mean it says it speaks for itself right
like the most important
like all the stuff before that is nice
and all but yeah yeah really necessary
yeah
sorry
i didn't actually do the questions
we took care of business later that
night
i mean that sounds sexual but oh i mean
we definitely took care of business that
night
[Music]
cutie you actually smile when i say
cheese
look at this yeah it's like really red
oh my gosh so luca's been like biting
his bottom lip because he's been
teething a lot
and he's been getting this rash but this
i don't know why this keeps coming up
and he scratched himself i just filed
his nails this morning look how look at
his nails
look at them they're so short i don't
know how he keeps let me see did he
keep scratching people and himself all
right so we are in front of the town
hall which i'm sure has way more
historical importance other than the
fact that it appeared in hocus pocus but
that's that's why it's famous to me
because focused
[Music]
and daddy's making them
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we just finished our tour
we had a tour of salem and they talked
about how many people died here
and it was very depressing all right so
look look at luka's cheek it's so bright
and casey he googled why is my baby's
cheek so red and the very first thing
that we saw
is because he's teething exactly he has
all the other symptoms he has like a
mild fever
like kind of like sort of mild fever
obviously biting everything rolling like
crazy now he has a one red cheek that's
another and he also had a slight fever
that was the first one i said i did okay
i know i drank a little too many of
these actually this is my first one
i just really like
isn't that funny daddy's so funny
[Music]
all right we are now walking around
newport newport rhode island and this is
actually the town
where cherry and anne are getting
married
no it's not two out of three events are
here in newport news
oh we can't afford it okay got it so we
drove from boston this morning to rhode
island which is a trip because it was
really short living in california living
in texas to to think about driving to
another state that's like a whole day
you know it's like six hours
yeah multiple hours
half a day four hours two hours but this
was under an hour this is this is
actually right at the hour mark so it
took us an hour to drive up here or down
here did we drive down or up i don't
even know so we drove down you're the
one driving
it's been a long day and it just started
and it just started
but yeah it's really nice here it's
really quaint and i like it very
romantic
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so now we are at carrie and bana's
uh pre-honeymoon
honeymoon suite this is a honeymoon
suite for sure this is so cool so if you
walk in you see all that that is the
usual stuff you might see well staircase
is pretty unique but guess what bam you
got a tub right there right in the
living room
our honeymoon suite in
[Music]
at barcelona this is so cool we got a
jacuzzi inside the room
and then and then in bed are you kidding
me
oh this is so cool i don't think we're
gonna see much of spain seeing my
brother go through his process of
getting married and all that stuff it
definitely brings back the feelings like
that i had
going through yeah like oh my gosh i'm
getting married
i'm super happy for them because like if
i know anything about going through all
this it's super dope it's nerve-wracking
but it's like there's no words for him
i'm about to get like all choked up
again so i'm like it's the best you guys
enjoy it i swear happy for you guys so
happy for you guys
[Music]
look at look at how you're so cute look
at that time look at my
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
you